[Music]
I need you all week all the time oh God
we'll just live inside your trousers or
something but it'll be much easier what
are you gonna turn into a pair of
knickers in it's the night of the 17th
of December 1989 and somewhere in the
English Countryside a radio Enthusiast
is scanning between frequencies often
used by police officers and pirate radio
DJs when he stumbles across a private
phone conversation between a man and a
woman oh darling I just want you now
dear so do I desperately desperately
desperately it's obvious that lovers but
would that be enough reason to press
record on a scanner I do love you and
I'm so proud of you oh I'm so proud of
you it's more that this man's voice
sounds familiar
to Queen Elizabeth II Future King of
England married to arguably the world's
most famous woman Diana Princess of
Wales the woman on the other end of the
line doesn't sound like his wife the
mother of his two young Sons William and
Harry it would be so wonderful to just
have one night to set us on our way
wouldn't it wouldn't it to wish you a
happy Christmas
who could he be talking to
this woman seemingly unknown
not only to the radio scanner but to
most people around the world
all of that will change when this
recorded tape goes public it will change
everything
greatest achievement is to love me oh
darling easier than falling off a chair
as our reconstruction reminds us this
sexually loaded conversation will make
Global headlines and in doing so
threaten the future of Prince Charles
and the monarchy as we know it we were
openly speculating
that he just couldn't
you just couldn't carry on who was The
Other Woman in the recording
it was to change her life in ways she
could never have imagined this 42 year
old married mother is about to become
Public Enemy Number One Camilla Parker
Bowles Camilla I think it's fair to say
was probably one of the most loathed
people in the country at the time
most of the future King will be a main
player in this scandalous soap opera
that was to take a very tragic turn
we're just receiving the the sad news
here at Sky Center that Diana Princess
of Wales has in fact been killed in that
car accident shocking unbelievable
tragedy Diana was dead Charles traveled
to Paris to bring back the body of his
ex-wife who was to blame for her death
how could Charles have left her for his
mistress Camilla hatred by the British
public of Camilla was to reach new
levels and would take another two
decades to dissipate
and in this love story no one ever could
have imagined that Camilla Parker Bowles
might one day be crowned but of course
it's a great honor it couldn't be
anything else
2023 and she does become Queen we've
spoken to the people who've been part of
this journey behind the scenes during
the dark days close friends former staff
I'm Kate Burley I'm from Sky News this
is Queen Camilla For the Love of Charles
[Music]
to understand this story and what
happens next we need to go back to the
beginning
foreign
[Music]
was born in London on the 17th of July
1947 at King's College Hospital to
Rosland and Bruce Shand a retired army
major
imagine an old 18th century Country
House set in more than five acres of
East Sussex Countryside with an orchard
a pool and a paddock this is where
Camilla Shand grew up her childhood
would leave an indelible Mark as she
explains in the ITV documentary
Camilla's Country Life
Summers were sort of idyllic because we
could go across the downs and into the
sea I love swimming and I love English C
I think she had a pretty fabulous
childhood though a little bit free range
the friend and author Kathy Lett
Camilla's childhood was something
straight out of an Enid Blyton novel
galloping horses over the Moors and a
wonderful brother who was a bit of a
rascal and a bit of a vagabond and I
think that she had such a close bond
with him you know imagine it was idyllic
the eldest of three children growing up
Camilla was very close to her youngest
sibling Mark she also had a sister
Annabelle born into wealth Camilla and
her siblings were part of Britain's
privileged Elite the queen consort
carries in her DNA the most remarkable
number of antecedent lines a family
lineage so notable that it's better
explained by the governor of Edinburgh
Castle and our Royal expert Major
General Alistair Bruce it's quite
difficult to find many families that
have perhaps so many links as the queen
consorts does to her husband's family
there was after all a relationship
through Henry Cavendish who was the
second Duke of Newcastle and that makes
both the queen consort and the King
ninth cousins once removed
age 10 Camilla left home for the private
Queen's Gate School in London South
Kensington
here to her friends she was known simply
as Miller popular but something of an
average student she would leave for
finishing school in Switzerland at the
age of 16 with just one-0 level I think
in some ways it was very restrictive the
world she grew up in girls were brought
up to be decorative and demure and when
she was coming of age was just the time
that the women's Liberation movement was
sparking off and yet she wasn't expected
to take any part in that you know she
had to be a debutant because girls were
really just sit in of that class would
just seemed to be a life support system
to their womb
thank you
by 1965 the now 18 year old Camilla
found work as a secretary in London but
her social life was to prove far more
significant a debutant Camilla attended
High Society social events for eligible
singles a place to meet the landed
gentry and even a prince or two she was
supposed to then be molded go to a
finishing school I mean even the term
finishing school is such a horrible
expression it's like you know your
Ambitions are over you are finished and
now we put on the Shelf until some man
picks you up as a trophy wife and put
you on his on his own mantelpiece so you
know I can imagine it was quite
restrictive
Camilla met Charles in the early 1970s
there was an instant attraction but the
relationship was considered unsuitable
by the royal family and Camilla was
instead to go on to meet and marry major
Andrew Parker Bowles
he was of good stock having been a page
boy at Queen Elizabeth II's coronation
back in 1953 but the connection with
Charles was unbreakable and they
continued on with their tryst Simon
McCoy with Sky News first Royal
correspondent Charles fell helplessly in
love with her at the time but she wasn't
suitable he became I suspect besotted in
a way with her but his life took him
somewhere else Kathy let I think
definitely Camilla found her knight in
shining Armani
and in Camilla I think Charles found a
woman who
didn't put him on a pedestal and could
see you know the vulnerability and the
gentleness of of him and not just being
awe not be over awed by the position
and that must be quite quite hard to
find a woman who's not overlord by that
and and the fact that she could tease
him you know and make him laugh and make
him feel make him feel real
[Music]
many of us could only dream of making
this romantic fairy tale connection but
it seemed to be a relationship that had
no future
Camilla was married to someone else even
if she divorced Andrew Parker Bowles a
senior member of the royal family at
that time Charles could never be seen to
be marrying a divorcee this relationship
just wasn't meant to be
it's now July 1975 in the Cotswolds
gloucestershire at cirencester Park
Country House where a polo game has just
finished
stood under a beech tree is a woman slim
with blonde hair and a red shirt it's
Camilla and she's deep in conversation
with one of the polo Players Prince
Charles behind them on the tree there's
a fresh carving their initials
intertwined a symbolic Declaration of
Love at least that's how I saw it at the
time she married her husband while still
having a relationship with Charles
because it was felt Jonathan ready also
told other women on the go as well
so he didn't choose Camilla then but she
stayed in his life and they were clearly
very close and she clearly meant an
awful lot to him this is Phil Craig
author of the best-selling book die
story of a princess
you traveled the world he had a series
of relationships with all the Glamorous
people he was a philosopher Prince I
think in his own mind happy in his
circle of friends he loved his life and
he didn't particularly want to change it
by now Camilla is mother to her first
child Tom the well-known food writer she
and Charles continue to be very close
friends
meantime the Royal household is focusing
on a more suitable Bride for the Playboy
Prince eligible young women like Lady
Sarah Spencer
she soon ties though of the Future King
telling Time Magazine she wasn't in love
with Charles I wouldn't marry anyone I
didn't love whether he were the dustman
or the king of England she's reported to
have said
Charles turns to her younger sister
Diana
everything Camilla wasn't unattached
virtuous and a virgin she was a perfect
match and an ideal future Queen
been raised in and around people like
Charles and people who've known Charles
and her own sister who were dated
Charles she knew so much about his
Circle she knew so much about his love
life and she knew an awful lot about the
man he was before she met him you know
and then that included Camilla
[Music]
thank you
from that quiet country setting the
story now moves to London and Saint
Paul's Cathedral
29th of July 1981 a throng six deep
camera Crews from four corners of the
globe are gathered a mind-boggling 750
million people around the world are
tuning in to watch the fairy tale
wedding of Prince Charles and Lady Diana
Spencer a new record for a live TV event
public interest in the love story of a
handsome prince and his 20 year old
bride is on a scale like no other
[Music]
I vividly remember watching Diana at the
time walking into Saint Paul's beautiful
young adored by the public the people's
princess
her wedding dress is an ivory silk
taffeta and an antique lace gown with a
25-foot train and 153 yards of chill
Vale the initials of the happy couple
embroidered onto the heel of each of her
shoes the magic of the moment remains
one of the stand-up memories of my
career as it was for my former colleague
Simon McCoy it was a remarkable day it
was
a day of Hope
Britain was in a difficult place it
might sound familiar and the focus of a
joyful day in July 1981 where the whole
country seemed to come together and
there was parties all around the country
the weather on the day was wonderful it
was just one of those days you would if
you were there you would never forget as
a day of happiness and that was
reflected also in them let's not forget
they were happy at the beginning and
they looked it and we all wanted that
marriage to work watching on were two
and a half thousand invited guests the
Queen the Duke of Edinburgh oversees
Royals including Grace Kelly and
a woman in a pale gray dress and a pill
box hat
Camilla
[Music]
as Diana floated down the aisle she
glimped up from underneath her legendary
Fringe and spotted Charles's close
friend his hunting partner his sometimes
dinner date
Camilla made every effort to be nice to
Dinah at the beginning
she invited her to her home they went
out for lunch she sent a little cards so
excited about the engagement can't wait
to see the ring Phil Craig again I think
that this accommodation as I call it
wasn't perfect sometimes if Camilla was
paraded too publicly dial it would kick
off
and get very cross but actually it did
sort of work for them in it and it funny
enough it's the period of Diana's real
rise to International public success in
those very early years he I suspect does
back off from
being Camilla's lover
but I do think he gave Diana every
reason to believe that he wasn't really
committing to the marriage with her
as Diana becomes Princess of Wales and
with Prince Charles they begin married
life together this joyous Union starts
to unstick
within months of the wedding the reality
of Life inside the royal family and a
growing awareness that her new husband
was continuing to remain in touch with
his old love becomes just too much for a
depressed Diana
desperate and four months pregnant with
Prince William
the young princess holds herself down a
set of stairs at Sandringham in which he
later says was a cry for attention from
her husband
through his work documenting the story
of Diana author Phil Craig says the
relationship between Charles and Camilla
would have been at the Forefront of
Diana's tormented mind and the story
that comes out from her is that as the
marriage to Diana unraveled Charles
began to need her again
not necessarily sexually just as a
friend somebody who could offer the kind
of support that Diana wasn't able to
offer didn't want to offer and I've no
doubt that they did become lovers again
not that long after the marriage
but I suspect that Camilla wanted Diana
to have
the chance to make the relationship work
and so in the summer of 1982 Diana gives
birth to Prince William two years later
he's joined by his little brother Harry
I remember the moments Diana and Charles
emerged from the private Lindo wing of
Saint Mary's Hospital in London cradling
each of their sons their faces beaming
to the outside world
the model family of four the camera
never lies they say or does it
no one outside of the palace and the
inner Circles of Camilla Charles and
Diana could have predicted the
ramifications that would soon emerge as
the perfect royal family disintegrated
not even Keen Royal Watcher Simon McCoy
I reported at the time that there were
rumors of unhappiness in the marriage I
actually have the piece of press
Association copy where Buckingham Palace
denied a report on Sky TV that the
marriage of The Prince and Princess of
Wales was in trouble there was no
speculation on earth that could would
ever have got near to the truth which
was much more devastating frankly than
anything the papers were saying might be
going on and they were saying plenty
there was a huge appetite from the
audiences about the stories for gossip
about the royal family this Fleet Street
Insider who was at the Forefront of
reporting the Royal story back in the
80s was about to play his part in one of
the Royal Family's biggest ever scandals
it asked us to use an actor to voice his
words there were very strict rules
around privacy and things phone hacking
wasn't even on the horizon no no so it
was just a telephone conversation and
and back then mobile phones were very
easy you could just you could buy a
scanner at the Tandy electric shop in
the High Street right and they were
about 200 quid anybody could get them
and mobile phones back in the late 80s
weren't digital they were all the um I
don't know what they were broadcasting
on but you could just you could buy one
of these scanners in the same way you
could listen to a police radio and
airline pilots you could also listen to
people's mobile phone conversations
whether that was legal or not nobody
really cared by 1989 the new technology
was being used not only by tabloid
journalists but curious radio
enthusiasts too one amateur stumbled on
the private conversation between Charles
and Camilla
what should he do with it
the recording Finds Its way to the
editor of the Daily Mirror Bots he faces
a quandary by publishing and exposing
the affair it may well threaten
Charles's succession to the throne and
the continuity of the royal family there
were also concerns about how a fragile
Princess Diana would react not to
mention possible legal action
the mirror decides not to publish the
bombshell contents of the tape locked
away in the newspapers safe you think
the Tableau journalist would just splash
anything on the front page but no they
were very very careful years pass the
public oblivious to the unraveling of
the royal marriage
then come allegations from Diana that
would change all of that
in late 1992 Andrew Morton publishes his
tell-all book written from the
transcripts of tapes smuggled to him
from Diana the book would blow the lid
on the lies and reveal the steamy and
ongoing Affair between Charles and
Camilla here's Andrew Morton talking
about what Diana had shared with him she
watches Camilla with a hooting and
morbid Fascination I remember that
shortly after the separation she
discovered where Prince Charles and
Camilla Parker Bowles met she found a
large-scale Ordnance survey map she
pinpointed where they met she worked out
the routes that Camilla would take the
route that Charles would get would take
as she thinks about well will Charles
become king will he will he run off with
his woman she doesn't know the answer to
these things only Camilla and Charles
know the answer to these things
Simon McCoy this book was seminal
because very quickly it was clear it was
Diana's I mean it was her true story as
the title of the book it was her story
much of it was true a lot of it was was
powered by the anger and grief of of a
woman who was feeling unloved at the
time and and that was very powerful
behind the scenes she was calling
Camilla a Rottweiler and that was a that
was a tag that stuck she surely it
couldn't be true the mirror though knows
that it is they have the tape
rumors continue to swirl in the drinking
haunts of Fleet Street journalists
something would have to give
newspapers start to suggest not all is
well behind the palace Gates
however who could ever have guessed
what would happen next
prime minister John Major
breaks the news to the nation
it is announced from Buckingham Palace
that with regret the prince and princess
of Wales have decided to separate
their Royal highnesses have no plans to
divorce and their constitutional
positions are unaffected
the situation was about to get a whole
lot worse for Charles and Camilla
[Music]
foreign
it's the morning of the 13th of January
1993. more than 10 000 miles from London
the other side of the world in Sydney
Australia and a little-known glossy
magazine new idea publish the biggest
story of its Hundred Year history they
have the tape remember a copy of which
is in the Daily Mirror safe back in
London The Mirror's lawyers too cautious
to have printed it at the time
Australia's less stringent libel laws
mean the details of Charles and
Camilla's teen-like exchange under wraps
for so long would soon be plastered on
front pages right around the world it
had been three years since the recording
of the private conversation the couple
had never expected that their raw
unedited love for each other could be
laid bare to the world
you're awfully good feeling your way
along uh stop I want to feel my way
along you all over you up and down you
and in and out oh Charles particularly
in and out now that is just what I need
at the moment but that's exactly what
happens new idea publish the transcript
in full Royal shocker Charles and
Camilla's Sensational love tape Charles
rocked by Camilla tapeshock Camilla
Gates may keep Charles off throne
British titles scramble to republish new
ideas report
it's out now it's uh you cannot stick
the cat back in the the bag once it's
out there's now a global village faxes
are sending this over to every Newsroom
in the country I mean there's some
journalists in my Newsroom acting it out
in front of their colleagues right now
playing the various parts Simon McCoy
the tapes when they came out were
utterly devastating the Sun newspaper
put them on a constant Loop that you
could dial into to listen to nobody
really knew the name Camilla Parker
Bowles until Camilla gate and the
release of this devastating conversation
between
Charles and Camilla which well left
nothing to the imagination in terms of
how far the relationship had gone up
Camilla gate and
tampon gate
were born the Press knew that Camilla
was having a relationship with Charles
long before it was published and then
eventually when it was starting to be
published nobody believed it it was just
gossip it's ridiculous this is just
gossip here's our Fleet Street Insider
again it was oh my God now we can
actually hear proof that Charles has
been cheating on Diana what a shadow
is this what the upper class do when
they have sex talk about wanting to be
tampons and things I mean I'm sure there
was criticism often of the newspapers is
sort of getting pruriance and intrusive
but I think from memory the overall
message was that the newspapers were
simply reflecting what the royal family
were doing which was you know being love
cheats for Prince Charles the tape was
cold hard humiliating proof of his
illicit Affair an affair which now
brought into question his suitability as
heir to the throne there were lots of
people saying he mustn't be king that
that they would have to skip a
generation there was so much anger Phil
Craig again people were openly
speculating that
That Couldn't he just couldn't carry on
I mean he's lied about this
it's treated this future Queen really
badly because they're still married
the separate at this point but they're
still married
I'll keep ahead of the Church of Kingdom
how can he be respect you know
respectable man again
the palace was in meltdown could this be
the end for Charles and Camilla could
this be the end for Charles as Future
King
when the Camilla Gate scandal was at its
height
a lot of people were saying this is it
Charles is in real trouble and Camilla
that's it for her Public Enemy Number
One universally hated Camilla now stood
to lose everything for the man she'd
risked everything for with rumors
reaching fever pitch over the prince's
Royal future and Camilla still then
Parker Bowles facing Fury both in public
and in her marriage
surely their love story was over
love you don't want to
see neither do I but you must get some
sleep
bye bye darling love you
Next Time on Queen Camilla For the Love
of Charles I'll uncover the tumultuous
aftermath of Camilla gate to suddenly
find yourself
as Public Enemy Number One and to be
such a hate figure and be kind of on the
dartboard of the national consciousness
must have been horrific what would the
future hold for The Prince and Princess
of Wales most people were thinking about
Diana and the effect this was all going
to have on her just we're just being the
the sad news here at Sky Center and a
horrific tragedy that would shock the
world
you can listen to all episodes now Queen
Camilla For the Love of Charles is a Sky
News podcast production presented by me
K Burley the producer is soila aparicio
assistant producers are Alex Eden and
Lily Thomas sound design is by James
Bradshaw Rob mulhern is the exec
producer and Paul stanworth the editor
[Music]